how did we begin uh what attracted me to
the project was that it was very clear
what was happening in the developing
world hundreds of millions of people in
Africa and the developing world were
getting cell phones this was the only
growth area in telephony in 2003 2004
the only segment that was making money
and it was changing the GDP of these
countries because every percent
penetration of cellphones you'd get you
know a certain amount of gdp growth but
there were studies showing that if you
could get data to these people not just
voice but data the impact could be three
four or five times greater for every
percent penetration you could get but
but how do you you know make something
for the developing world and get them to
them no that's when I ran into Nicholas
Negroponte a who said hey you know let's
make a hundred dollar laptop and let's
get the government's to buy the laptops
on mass and give them you know one two
one one laptop per child and I thought
oh my gosh Nicholas figured out the
business model of course we became
nonprofit to do this business but then
it became my job to make the
hundred-dollar laptop cost a hundred
dollars which you know it is a little
bit more expensive we could have hit 150
it's at 188 and there's reasons for that
and I can I can defend them but still
the lowest cost laptop ever made the
lowest power laptop ever made and the
greenest laptop ever made and all of
that comes from looking at it from the
screen backwards the screen is what
people see when they see the laptop
there could be little green men inside
of electronics wouldn't wouldn't make
any impact to somebody looking at the
laptop the screen and the housing or
what we see and so if you can lower the
cost of this screen and the electronics
behind it and lower the power
consumption
deliver amazing results the whole
architecture the display most displays
have motherboards so the question was
how do you make a display that costs
less than a hundred dollars because
that's a real barrier to $100 laptop and
what what do you do with the motherboard
it was very clear we had to get rid of
the hard disk right and moved to what we
call flash and use a smaller processor
skinny down the operating system and
also massively lower the power
consumption but that really came from
choosing really noticing working with
with with the the chip manufacturer I
asked them a question I asked him every
month for about six months and they
finally answered this question how much
power does it take to just keep the
screen on even if the pixels aren't
changing well the answer was 223 watts
and at that point I had reinvented a
screen that was you know one watt
instead of usual a usual screen asst is
like seven watt power consumption and so
so I just thought that was stupid to
sort of keep a cpu on to you know
consume 2 to 3 watts plus the whole
motherboard just to drive a screen with
the same pixels on all the time say
you're reading something and just the
pixels aren't moving around there's no
video on the screen everything's sort of
the same well it turns out that um I
know a lot of ups way but maybe the
people you know I didn't know this is
going to be so technical I'm just
wondering how to do a technical talk to
a non technical audience
you